on episode 4 of potatoes a hundred
different ways I'm making this super
cheesy foam oligo I've never had
potatoes like this before look at that
wow this traditional French Potato dish
required some steps but it was
definitely worth it after boiling the
potatoes I passed them through a ricer
then worked on the herb cream sauce
infusing it with a medley of delicious
herbs I then transferred it to the rice
potatoes whisking until fully
Incorporated and cooking over low heat
until the mixture becomes a little
sticky and thickened this is where the
magic happens I added grated gruyere and
batches stirring until this stringy
goodness happens look at that this is a
solid 10 out of 10.